[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
actually love and that has meaning
create real amazing and actual
relationships christina ellis ramsey
personality best-selling author is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five tom
starts us off this hour in pittsburgh
hey tom what's up buddy
hey dave thank you so much for taking my
call i appreciate it sure how can we
help
hey my question is i've been
self-employed for seven years now and
i'm just looking to make a transition
out of what i currently do the business
climate's just becoming more and more
difficult to operate in more and more
competitors and i'm looking to scale
myself out of what i do now and
transition back into working for someone
else and i just i've tried made a couple
attempts but just find it to be pretty
challenging
okay what were the road what were the
speed bumps
um it seems difficult to get hired
because i have limited experience my
background's in management accounting i
only have about two years of relevant
field experience
in the accounting world but um i have my
i've had my own business now for for
seven years going on eight and it just
seems to be difficult to get recognized
to get hired coming from self-employment
like employers don't value the skill set
that i can bring to the table
what were you doing what kind of
business
property maintenance and landscape
installation
okay
how many employers have you reached out
to at this point
um
i've been through the interview process
about six times uh
applications probably 20 to 30.
what size companies
mainly
medium size what are you applying for
project manager positions okay
well it sounds to me like you have like
seven years of project manager
experience too correct i i have seven
years of project management experience
now it's smaller scale i mean i'm doing
ten thousand dollar jobs not ten million
it doesn't matter if you put a task in
front of you and you map out the
incremental details to accomplish the
task and you push the task through on
schedule that's called project
management
it's not rocket science
i agree
uh so um i maybe
you need to think about how to sell
the fact that that how these skills are
transferable
uh a in the initial contact and b in the
actual interview itself
and then c what you're looking for is a
business that has an entrepreneurial
enough bent
like for instance i mean i own this
business and i have 1200 employees so
i'm a fairly large company
but i would recognize or one of our
leaders would recognize that that what
you've been doing is project management
i mean you know you may not have a
certification in pm at the pm3 level or
something but i mean you're knocking
stuff out and so um you know like when
we sit down
same thing what we're looking for is the
skill
set that is already in existence and can
you apply that in the workplace if they
are so stupid in corporate that they're
looking for some kind of a the fact that
you've done the exact thing that they
want done at five other places working
for corporate america you probably don't
wanna work there anyway you're gonna go
crazy
i think you're right
you're probably right i'm just so used
to being in my own world my own realm of
things and managing my own shows you're
probably right
but but in other words if they've got a
little bit of an entrepreneurial flair
they would see
these transferable skills yeah and
that's been my journey i mean i was an
entrepreneur for 10 years before i came
here to ramsey yeah and then you went to
work here who knew yeah that's right
and i appreciate that one of the core
values here is having a self-employed
mentality it's been a great transition
because i'm now at a company that values
that skill set and it's been able to
translate really well more than value we
kind of just expect you to do it right
[Laughter]
it's like why we brought you home
because you knew how to kill something
drag it home you know right that's
exactly right i didn't even think about
that that's a good point yeah and tom
i'm curious with the companies you've
worked for over the last seven years are
there any employers that you've
partnered with and done project
management with that maybe want to bring
you on full time
a couple but they don't have the the
capabilities for somebody full time at
the moment i've done some work with some
larger
apartment complexes and done some
subcontracted work through some property
management companies and there was no
opportunity available at the at the time
for that um maybe as they grow they
could grow into a full-time position but
it's a it's a present no yeah i think
you've got two issues that i'm hearing
and i would refer you to king coleman's
materials as well i'll send you a copy
of his book from paycheck to purpose for
you to have in your library and read it
too but the uh uh the two things are one
is i want to be careful of the words i'm
using the sentence structure i'm using
to describe
my past experience
instead of describing it as i ran a
landscaping company describe it as um
you know we i owned and operated and
completed projects
um
you know and so forth and as a part of
my deal so you're it's an honest and a
truthful description of what you had to
do as a small business owner and um
then the second thing you're looking for
is you're actually looking for a company
that has a an entrepreneurial culture to
it
and not all of these
uh corporate america goobs have a you
know a lot of them are just they've lost
their soul and you don't want to work
for them anyway
i mean so you know you want to find
somebody that's getting it i don't care
they can be a huge company but they've
got you know they got some
entrepreneurial get it you know
uh so there can be a medium-sized
company but you can you can get lost we
fight it around here i mean one of our
core values is we shoot our sacred cows
if we see a secret cow cow wandering
through the halls moving we get the gun
and kill it right there and we have
dinner i mean it's
you know if you cannot answer the
question why are we still doing this
this way if you don't have a good answer
for that that's a sacred cow and that's
how bureaucracy sets in in any
organization and rigor mortis sets in in
their brains
and so you just you just have to look
for that
um because it's out there and and the
truth is it's
fairly uh
you know it's it is it's inspiring to
work with a team that's energized an
entrepreneur absolutely
rather than being on your own being the
lone ranger it's hard being the lone
ranger and um it's one of the laughable
things about the work from home movement
is everybody thinks it's somehow going
to be now you lose all the benefit of
human beings
raising you up to another level you lose
the benefit of all the synergy of
creativity and the connectivity of
having great people around you calling
you out on your stuff man yeah and get
you know fighting together for a project
that's one of the reasons why i wanted
to come work here was just having that
team and that energy and everybody gets
to be excellent at their own role but we
come together and then create something
really excellent altogether yeah that's
true i mean that is very true we can
take someone uh that that has the kind
of initiative and intelligence and
background that you've got and then
bring you into a bunch of other people
that think the same way and all of a
sudden it's you know
the definition of synergy is two things
come together and they're better than
the sum of the parts you know and that's
what happens when we bring a personality
on it's also what happens when we bring
a programmer on they're a better
programmer
than sitting at home going d d d d d d
you know so um you actually it's a
different thing man because i mean you
could do tasks as individuals but you
can't create
and don't have vision
as in and you can but it's it's much
limited than when you have access to
other human beings messing with you
human beings supposed to mess with each
other that's why we have this show
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
imagine a
jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to experience
what it means to live life to the
fullest can you feel the energy
picture all your favorite speakers all
the ramsey personalities including
christina
on the stage me too i'll be there
empowering you with tools and principles
that create unstoppable momentum we talk
about every area of your life in smart
conference and when you leave it's a
day-long conference it's called smart
conference and at the end of the day i
promise you will be smarter that's the
whole idea saturday october the 22nd in
dallas tickets are on sale right now
they're only 39
that's a great price for a full day
event we should charge 390 for this
lineup of speakers talking about mental
wellness uh becoming a millionaire uh
getting out of debt uh marriage uh
pastor craig groschel amy groschel from
life church are coming to speak on
marriage it's gonna be incredible uh
we'll be talking about your career we'll
be talking about winning in every area
of your life it won't touch it all it's
going to be incredible and you don't
want to miss this it's going to be again
saturday october the 22nd go to
ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more ramseysolutions.com
events our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping new promos all the
time this is an incredible american
company if you need blinds or window
treatments for your homeblinds.com use
the promo code ramsey get the best deal
today's question comes from jenna in
florida i'm starting college in the fall
and i have scholarships to pay about 70
percent of tuition
what do i do to make up the gap gonna be
a long summer jenna
i love this question
well of course you can still apply for
more scholarships that's the first and
easiest spot to kind of start going with
it you already have 70 which is great i
don't know if that's tuition
scholarships that are covered just
automatically because you went to a
certain school but i encourage you to
apply for outside scholarships
a lot of students don't realize that
when you get to college you can still
apply for scholarships they think you
know i passed high school this is it i
can't get scholarships but there are
tons of outside scholarships for people
who are in college who are in grad
school so definitely keep applying i
actually have a friend who didn't start
applying for scholarships until she was
in college and was able to still get
enough money to pay for tuition books
housing everything so even if you were
past high school
for her to look for those well we like
scholarshipowl.com that's a great
database i recommend students use these
scholarship databases which are
basically search engines for
scholarships they specifically take your
information and find targeted
scholarships for you now we looked at i
had a lady asked me the same question
the other day and i told her we had
looked at several of these
databases and the problems with some of
them is
the uh there there's kind of two types
of scholarships out there there's ones
that are legitimate but not everybody
knows they're there they're kind of hard
to find sometimes and then other times
there's somebody that's basically trying
to
they're fishing just to get your
information so they can try to sell you
something later you know what i'm
talking about absolutely how do you tell
the difference in those well it's
important to dig deeper into the company
find out is it a credible company what's
their heart and mission behind the
scholarship why are they giving away a
scholarship like do your research a lot
of people just find scholarships and
they automatically think you know i
should apply for the scholarship but one
of the most in time-intensive parts of
applying for scholarships is actually
making sure you find the right
scholarships so take time to dig through
and see if these companies are legit and
see what they're all about and see what
the odds are of winning that scholarship
a lot of them are kind of sweepstakes
type scholarships you know so how how is
jenna going to find time to do this
because i was getting ready to tell her
to work 80 hours a week this summer
that was next on my list of things to do
is work i mean we've actually found that
students who work part-time do better in
school than students who don't work at
all so it is important to have a job
even if you don't necessarily need the
money like jenna does you know still
work it can help you create that
discipline but if you do need the money
that's the way to go like pour into
getting a job and work strategically a
lot of companies offer tuition
assistance and tuition benefits so
not only can you get a paycheck but they
may actually pay for part of your
tuition so yes
target amazon starbucks several of them
are doing this yeah
yeah and they're off on all kinds of
scholarship options and or
tuition benefits while you work there
you might even keep working there while
you're in school it won't hurt you a bit
but here's the thing okay
if you just really did work like three
jobs
and uh you try to solve a grown-up
problem with like a grown-up solution
no whining about i went my hammer off
you're like a grown-up and you're
dealing with a grown-up problem here
which is you want to go to school you
don't have the money
and so sorry you're not 12.
uh welcome to the big leagues kiddo
uh get your butt in gear and go make
some money
work work work work work work work it's
a surefire money making scheme this work
thing
yeah go you know go get that go get that
20 30 an hour babysit walk dogs i don't
care what you do adore dash i don't care
what you do but just work all the time
between now and time you go to school
and you'll have the money yep the
magical magical magical i was super
excited and you won't have to underspend
it because you'll be at work all the
time
i talked to somebody at building wealth
and he had just received his bachelor's
in accounting and he's trying to figure
out how to pay for his master's degree
and we started brainstorming ideas
looking at second jobs and i recommended
that he talk to his employer to see if
they happen to have any tuition benefit
programs or a way that he could make up
the money and he just sent me a message
the other day on instagram saying that
he talked to his employer and they
offered him three to four
part-time assignments that were extra in
addition to his normal full-time job and
he's going to be able to completely
cover his master's degree right over
time yeah i mean he's got like
accounting type overtime that's not
that's not that's good money yep that's
a whole lot better than walking dogs i'm
saying that's great yeah suggestion good
result so that's what you do boys you
get scholarships uh uh you pick a school
you can afford which i assume you
already have because you got 70 of it
covered
and um then we go to town making money
and finding free money and those are
your keys
that's the three main things and go
ahead and plan on working while you're
in school
a couple things happen
like christina said we found student
athletes and people who work while
they're in school tend to have higher
gpas
and they learn time management skills
because they don't have a lot of time
so they have to go between work and
going to class you ain't got time to
play beer pong
so um it's an amazing thing and uh we we
see that happen over and over and over
again the other thing that
working students have a tendency to do
is graduate on time mm-hmm because
they're freaking one out
they're paying for it which is a huge
deal we're gonna ride the lazy river you
know oh my god like if you want to save
money on college that's like a one make
sure you graduate in four years it's
crazy the statistics around how many
students do not graduate in four years
and how many students actually take six
years or longer i think it's like 40
take six years or longer which when you
think about that two extra years that's
so much money so it's like very no
that's her parents fault they should
have cut them off
see i told mine they have four years
and you know have a plan there's a
little thing called a syllabus you just
work if you go to those classes for four
years you magically graduate it's
freaking amazing
follow the plan execute i mean
and don't tell me you got too much to do
give me give me a break i mean this is
grown-up stuff yeah this is grown-up
stuff and so we're solving a uh
a grown-up problem with a child's
mentality too often and that's how we
end up with 200 000 of student loan debt
for a degree in left-handed puppetry
well and that's the sad thing is a lot
of times that students taking out
student loans to cash flow this it's not
just even parent money and that's part
of the reason why we really got to clamp
down on this toxic industry that just
allows students to borrow money you know
as much as they want for years of
college you know we really got to get
students to be more disciplined and like
you said follow the syllabus and get gra
get your degree in time and just don't
waste that extra
time and money now when uh senator
marcia blackburn was here the other day
you were wrong with me right yep and i
asked her on the air so what are we
going to get rid of when are you going
to quit making student loans before we
start talking about forgiving them
and she went
yeah that's a good idea
come on marsha you can do it you can do
it uh yeah you can't talk about
forgiving something because it's evil
and bad while you keep making it that's
intellectually dishonest
so we have to stop this ridiculous out
of control business that is called
congress oh my gosh so
good job 70 i'm proud of you you already
got a bunch of it covered jenna you got
the right stuff
so christina gave you the sweet answer
go get more scholarships i gave you the
old grandpa answer get your butt in gear
and go to work this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions many of you are dropping by
while you're vacating and hanging out
with us having a
cup of free coffee a
free chocolate chip cookie homemade
and then you get to watch um
watch the zoo animals inside the glass
booth do their thing from one to four in
the afternoon
central time we'd love to have you come
by any of you want to come by we're in
franklin tennessee just south of
nashville god's country is what we call
it
and uh we're glad you're here come by
and see us anytime in the lobby also is
the debt-free stage where glenna is
standing hi glenna how are you hey dave
hi christina hi welcome good to have you
where do you live uh bellingham
washington just a spitting distance to
canada oh okay yeah cool welcome all the
way over to the side of the world thank
you and here to do a debt-free scream
how much did you pay off 360 100
how long did this take eight years wow
okay and your range of income during
that time i started at 90 and now i'm at
about 150. good for you what do you do
for a living i'm a rheumatology nurse
practitioner oh wow that's from good
work yes sir good for you
okay so eight years and 360 000 was that
your house yes sir looking at a weird
lady
she's a weirdo the house is paid for
i love it what's this house worth girl
733 thousand dollars
[Laughter]
i love it how much you got in retirement
savings about 600 she's a millionaire
she's a baby steps millionaire i'm
looking at a millionaire i love you
you're awesome thank you you're so in
control of your life very well done so
tell us your story what in the world
happened here about eight years ago i
got recruited by a rheumatologist i was
in shreveport louisiana
and i got recruited up to bellingham and
got a great raise but i also got a big
mortgage to go with it
and
as my dad my late dad used to say i got
wall-to-wall carpeting and back to the
wall payments
i've never heard that that is great
that's a good louisiana saying it is yes
sir i like it yes sir and all the wall
carpeting and back to the wall payments
yes sir i don't have to remember that
one yeah and uh
so i determined that i'm single and and
if i was ever going to retire i needed
to be able to pay off my mortgage
and so i worked really hard but then
covet hit and
it got my serious attention because i
scared the bee jeebers out of me
and thinking i'm going to lose my job
because we didn't have telemedicine yet
or anything like that so we eventually
got all that together but i didn't know
if i was going to lose my job my house
my income everything like that wow so
yeah and i'm a marine corps veteran dave
and so i can do hard
but i was scared
those scary times it was scary times and
so the last two years i paid off more
than half of the mortgage whoa yes sir
wow so what kind of things did you do to
get out of debt
um just focus intensity
i just
you know didn't vacation i
never ate out and the people at work
used to laugh at me because they would
all order lunch and everything and i
always brought my with me you know i
never ordered out never went out to
dinner and and coven made it easier
because nobody could go out anyway right
yeah yeah especially get extra hours and
stuff during coveter no sir i just um
once i started budgeting you just
cranked it down to nothing i did and
scared you enough that you went i'm
going bare bones and then i had the
money all of a sudden because i was
budging and i knew where the money was
going so money came up all of a sudden
and i was able to get bonuses and all
this other stuff that just came out of
the blue and it all went to the mortgage
every bit of it
how's it feel to be free
it's
it's amazing yeah
it's uh i mean when you're doing this by
yourself and you get the jebus scared
out of it yes sir there's a release when
you get the other side of it and i lost
120 pounds during that time
you lost a backstreet boy yes sir
wow yes unless justin bieber oh my gosh
wow
wow look at you that's amazing yeah and
you did all that during covent too yes
sir okay well uh i don't wanna say it
wasn't cause you ate didn't eat because
i hope you ate healthy while you were
doing that i did i did oh my gosh i mean
you're a nurse you know better but yeah
yeah
necessarily
so you're a free
you know payment in the world yes sir
you've got me over a million dollar net
worth me and a half
and uh you can do anything you want to
do what are you going to do to celebrate
i'm going in september to france
where um starting in paris because i'm a
veteran i really wanted to go see
normandy you need a cd day yeah i have
always wanted to go stand on the top of
those cliffs i've been up there a couple
times yeah and watch uh saving private
ryan before you
the veterans say is the real deal and
it's uh it was brutal i mean it's a
shooting guy it's horrible and you see
the price that was paid for american
freedom it just absolutely that part of
france they like americans yes sir yeah
because there's enough white stones up
there to remind them oh my it's as big
as arlington up on top yes sir and my my
scripture of the day
is first timothy 6 6
with godliness and contentment is great
gain amen and my big thing was being
content
i grew up with financial instability so
i had a hard time telling myself no
about anything
and so finding contentment was the
secret that's a breakthrough yeah so for
other people who are by themselves and
they think you know i'm alone i don't
have a spouse i don't have somebody you
know to walk through this journey with
me paying off the house seems
unrealistic it does what would you tell
them
one baby step at a time
um you know it does seem insurmountable
when you look at that number
but
the freedom on the other side just kept
me going and i of course i watch the
show every day and the debt free screams
i just watch them binge watching you
know because it gave me hope
that i could do it well you set such a
great example that it can be done no
matter your situation your circumstances
if you're willing to buckle down get on
a budget and do the work it can be done
yes amen i'm so proud of you thank you
who are your biggest cheerleaders my
family brought them with you two my
brothers are here i have three brothers
this is ernie and teresa they're from um
fort worth and my brother mike from
california
my other brother dan and his wife anita
are in washington state and they
couldn't make it but it's my family got
the whole gang around you and they're
saying touchdown sis absolutely and i
would like to give a couple shout outs
if i have time sure so my family for
sure
my pastor chris line gang and my
cornerstone
community church family
and my financial planner karen richards
with wells fargo
she kept telling me i was not going to
be a bag lady
and i turned out i wasn't and you're not
i'm not a bag actually you are but it's
a really big bag
it's a fake
big bag of money
[Laughter]
so i'm retiring september 1st all right
yes sir
look at you yeah wow
good for you well i'm so proud of you
very very well done i appreciate it well
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you because you is one yes sir and
uh you can read it and spread the love
around on that we'll also give you a
copy of the total money makeover to give
away to somebody i'm sure you've got
people in your life that you've inspired
with this journey and also
a subscription to financial peace
university for a year and you can give
that away or go through it yourself um i
mean you might learn one or two things
in there but you got most of this going
so very very well
good good stuff very very very good job
you're amazing you're a lot of fun thank
you thank you for your service and
thanks for sharing your story you did an
incredible job wow yeah yeah d-day you
got to go there absolutely gotta go
there north of france good time good
time wow all right it's glenna from
bellingham washington houses paid off
house and everything
this woman's a weirdo i love her 360 000
paid off half of that in the last two
years but the whole thing in eight years
and uh that's what happens when you get
serious oh while we're at let's lose 120
pounds when we make 90 to 150. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
thank god i'm debt-free
[Applause]
that's how it's done
that's why i keep coming to work
that's why i keep coming to work right
there amen oh what a neat lady how
powerful
and um
a lot of singles out there facing this
stuff and you're right sometimes it can
be lonely while you're doing it but get
some people in your corner get into a
good church a good financial peace
university class get your family around
you and get after it get it get it look
at her
she did it it's the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey ship i
am dave ramsey open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five amy is with us in
dallas texas hi amy how are you
i'm doing well mr ramsay how are you sir
better than we deserve what's up
um i got a quick question i'm pretty
sure i know the answer because i'm no
stranger to you okay but
my husband and i work for a large cap
company to be descriptive and over the
years we've built up a stock balance
through escp options that we've received
all those happenings
should i sell it
and put into mutual funds what's it all
about
what's it all worth uh it's worth about
700 000
which is about 30 percent of my net
worth
i'm
maxing out all my retirement already and
i'm not in a position where i have to
sell it it's on porn okay
so i was coaching a lady with procter
and gamble about
yeah that's time gets away from me must
be 25 years ago
and i honestly have no idea what procter
gamble stock is doing today it might be
wonderful
but she had 750 000 it was her whole
nest egg and she had it all in company
stock she was a png employee png is a
good company by the way again i have no
idea about investing in them at all
but this is just an observation of what
happens when you have all your money in
company stock or 30 percent of your net
worth and company stock
it went uh down 68 percent
and her 700 000 turned into like 150 000
because she violated the rule of
diversification
and um
the the the rule 10
yeah maximum of 10 of your net worth and
the reason for that is if it all if it
evaporates and became worth zero you're
still okay you still got 90
but i don't really want you to lose
30 percent of your net worth
and i'm not saying your large cap
company's going broke i'm not predicting
that i doubt they will if they're large
cap honestly
but i just i personally wouldn't take
that much risk and you already knew that
you knew i was going to say that right
yes i had a feeling um i guess i'm torn
because it's like it's gone it has gone
down a little bit but it's if you had
700 000 in in the middle of the table in
cash would you go buy this stock or
would you put it in mutual funds
i i am still torn on that decision
because i'm you know i was like oh it's
low i can't you would bet 30 of your
portfolio on one column no no i don't
know
that's why i do know that's dumb
i was trying to get you to say it but
i'll just say it okay no don't do that
that's too much of your net worth that
you've got at risk in one play and
you're emotionally involved because you
work there you're still impressed with
the company
right and here's the weird thing they
can be an impressive company their
stocks still suck
yeah i mean you can still like them and
still think they're good people
and still get your head taken off
okay now i guess second question is
should i sell it all at once or should i
space it out over time
uh is it doing pretty well right now
i mean it's okay i mean i'm still ahead
i guess um but i mean i don't think any
really i don't think anybody in single
stock is doing well right now i don't i
don't think you're gonna sell it all at
once
yeah
because i'm trying to just get you to
sell some of it now
so i think it's probably better for you
to ease out of it as long as you
actually do it
i'm not gonna let you off the hook
though you do need to get rid of at
least get down to where it's no more
than ten percent of your net worth okay
yeah and then if you're just dying to
own it then that's fine i i've i listen
my net worth several hundred million i
don't have a single single stock in my
portfolio not one
i don't like the risk
i like the risk
yeah i mean i guess i'll continue to
gain on it because i get it like every
year as a yeah so it's gonna build back
up so you really need to cut it down to
about five percent
yeah so you don't have to do this again
in two years
right yeah okay spread your portions to
seven yes to eight for you do not know
when disaster may come upon the land
ecclesiastes
it's even in the bible to diversify
wow how wild is that i always say
because you do not know when a pandemic
may come up online right
it's just stone i mean you can't you
just can't do that i mean i don't even
want all my
money in one type of real estate
i'm a little heavy in these buildings
right here but
because i've got because i own all these
buildings and they're worth several
hundred million but um we're grateful
but but it's i believe i'm okay because
i'm the tenant too but but who knows let
me see that's that could be a problem
but
um but yeah you just you just got to be
careful to not uh put all your eggs in
one basket because some idiots twirl in
the basket i like the way you said if
you had 700 000 on the table what would
you do with it i think that's a good way
to kind of disconnect from the fact that
it's her company that she kind of has a
biases already because it's where she
works i think that's a good way to kind
of separate things yeah well i mean
here's the thing she's a player
she's got a high risk tolerance because
her thing is oh it's going up
she it's going to be a great investment
you know and so that's she's got that
high risk tolerance thing going but um
but i've been on the other side of that
when i see the thing turned back down
and so um
i'm not going to um
to lead you that way and you're right
what happens is even if you're not
connected to the emotion of the company
you can be connected to
oh i really believe in this company
stock i think this you know i'm gonna
buy apple i believe it i don't own any i
don't work for apple i own an iphone
it's my extent of my investment but i
believe apple's a great investment so
i'm now i'm emotionally connected to
this single stock and that's probably a
great stock if you were going to do one
i don't i don't pick single stock so i
can't don't don't take my advice on that
i'm using that as an example
but the um
but but uh you know you can become
connected to it and what that does is it
it
it makes you say
all right well maybe i wouldn't put it
all in there then why are you
because it's the same transaction
and that that sunk cost analysis makes
you look at it that way leland is in
phoenix highly lin how are you
i'm doing all right how are you great
how can i help
so um
a current officer uh lieutenant and i uh
i'm in the middle of selling a rental
house that i own free and clear it's in
esco right now i plan on getting around
205 and whatever they take from it cool
um so i'm sitting at
my current debt right now i owe 17 on
cars and 90 on a house
um and i'll be completely debt free okay
but i'm i also own
land that i plan on building
and retiring on
so when uh land lands free and clear
when will you feel
well that's my question i'm gonna retire
in about 10 years i want to start
building within the next five it takes
you five years to build a house
well
you know i gotta get the subdivision and
everything it's not gonna take me that
long but it's about a five hour trip
back and forth and i have family that
can do it
but i wanna at least start the
foundation within five years so that it
will be done
within like two years of my retirement
dude you are a planner that's absurd you
do not need to start you don't need to
build a house for five years it'll be
rotted by the time you get it under roof
no okay and you build a house in 12
months really i mean
unless you're building some gargantuan
thing or something then you're not
so yeah but you do need to save some
money and keep planning and moving in
that direction so you're going to be
debt-free and you're going to invest the
most the money in like a mutual fund to
get ready to build on this property in
uh seven or eight years right
yes okay yeah that was my question do i
put it all towards the mutual fund yeah
or do i
you don't need it for seven or eight
years on the debt that i have no you pay
off all the debt you have you're 100
debt free
okay and then that's going to do yeah
how much time what's your tax bill going
to be on this thing
that i have no idea you got it i got to
set that money aside
yeah so pay off pay off your house pay
off your car get on a budget never
borrow money again raise your right hand
i'll never borrow money again
i'll never borrow money again okay and
then you got to pay your taxes and it
sounds to me like you have like 70 grand
left over to put a mutual fund towards
your house
okay and that's that's i'll throw it in
a mutual fund and call it a date should
i throw it in my 457 that i already have
going nope or should i be pulling all
that out you can't a 457 is deferred
comp and this is not comp
you can't you can't it has to run
through your work
yeah
you don't even need to put it in an ra
just put it in a mutual fund get in
touch with one of our smart investor
pros because you're just parking it for
seven years how old are you
39 okay and you're in the military right
no no no uh corrections oh okay you said
lieutenant you threw me okay cool all
right yeah yeah you're good you got
plenty of time no you don't want that in
a mutual i mean you just want a mutual
fund not in a
retirement account so and in all your
planning i think it'd be awesome if part
of that plan is building that house with
cash to set that as part of your goal is
building that house five years from now
seven years from now seven years from
now with cash
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships well two of my
favorite guys stopped by we'll hang out
a little bit joshua milburn and ryan
nicodemus known as the minimalists
they are world famous and two of the
coolest guys i know i'm always a little
cooler when i hang out with y'all for a
few minutes oh keep going
it's it's honor to have you come by
thanks for swinging by nashville and
seeing us and let's just start with the
important stuff is the new film
les is now
nominated for an enemy
congrats guys man
never in my life if you'd have told me
like you know 20 years old you're going
to be nominated for an emmy i'll be like
really it's crazy crazy it's weird yeah
i don't know i'm in it yet
so when they find out i'm in it you'll
get disqualified but yeah but but it was
fun for a minute yeah it was great it
was going to show up
right if you win i'm going to just take
all the credit though i would love it
it it'll go right there on the shelf
we're just going to take the award we're
going to take dave ramsey and then get
off the stage well that's what mike rowe
did on the borrowed future documentary
we did he said yeah the reason it was so
successful was that you had me in it
because humility is one of mike's things
so great
same stuff guys well cool guys thanks
for coming by now we're working on a new
project together
um
that i am so excited about uh if you
don't know who the minimalists are
minimalism is uh it is an art and a
science that these guys have uh found it
initiated and gotten lots of people to
get their
lives decluttered and get some
meaningful lives
uh when it comes to the stuff and your
your interaction and your view of stuff
if you haven't seen their documentaries
read their books be sure and look up the
minimalists and learn every bit of that
but the story starts of youtube before
you were minimalist when you were
materialistic
like all of the rest of us um
you were you're growing up in ohio and
your childhood friends yeah yeah we've
known each other since we were fat
little fifth graders yeah yeah
true story now dave we grew up really
poor and we thought we were so unhappy
because we didn't have any money and so
when i turned 18 i spent my 20s spending
basically it wasn't my money because i
was always spending toward the next
promotion the next paycheck i got that
corporate job and was climbing the
corporate ladder and always spending
spending spending until i got to a point
where i had nearly half a million
dollars in debt
and ostensibly i was successful people
looked at me and said they saw the
luxury cars the big suburban house with
more toilets than people all the stuff
to fill every corner of my
consumer-driven life
and we were sort of living the old
american dream not realizing that this
wasn't a dream it was a nightmare and it
was a nightmare because
we had so much debt and that's really
why we're here today is we want to help
all of the kids in in and around dayton
ohio our hometown
learn how to
well how to stay out of debt yeah
so our high school curriculum is
foundations in personal finance it's now
been taught in about 45 percent 48
percent actually of america's high
schools all across america
pretty pretty incredible but you guys
came alongside us and said okay we want
to we want to sponsor
a ramsey education crowd funding
initiative yeah and i put it out to your
audience and then your audience can come
in and help you sponsor this for ohio
schools where you guys are from yeah so
they can go through and because what's
ended up happening the reason we become
good personal friends is is that our
messages overlap so much and so does our
fan bases yeah that matter our tribes uh
where you've taught people to
uh you know live with less and we teach
them to live on less yeah and so uh it's
a good combo a good tag team absolutely
so um it's pretty cool so where did the
financial literacy
connection work i mean
it's obvious to me but an underhand
pitch question is where does that where
does your passion for that come from
just the whole background the whole
backstory of materialism yeah just
growing up poor and um yeah i had the
magic equation uh if i could make 50 000
a year i'd be happy and i got that
equation from my dad who uh he had a
painting and wallpaper business and uh i
worked with him during the summers
in high school and we're working at this
really nice house and i'm like how much
do i need to make in order to own a
house like this and he's like son if you
can make 50 000
you could probably own a house like this
so
i thought all right that's what i'm
going to do yeah that's rich
by the way yeah right exactly it was in
the 90s i made 50 000 um but i wasn't
happy so i'm like well you know it's
time has passed a little bit i didn't
adjust for inflation so then you know i
made 65 000 100 000
and uh you know through through that uh
that adventure i borrowed a lot of money
and i really got myself stuck in a lot
of debt and now you know like josh was
saying we're kind of living that old
american dream and now you know josh and
i feel like the new american dream is
really living a debt-free life and what
we want to do is help these kids start
off their life the right way i mean it's
unfortunate but you know a lot of people
in this society the majority of them are
financially illiterate and it's not our
fault right i mean we're just we're not
taught how to manage our money as as
kids you know we get talked into to
spend the money we don't have to buy
things we don't need to impress people
we don't like and man if josh and i can
help some kids um avoid that pain and
suffering that's compounded by debt uh
that would really um that would really
make us feel good now of course we can't
do this by ourselves we got to ask you
know everyone for their help to do this
but uh yeah you can you can donate five
bucks 25 bucks 45 bucks so five dollars
uh it doesn't matter what you donate 25
will pay for a middle school curriculum
45 pays for high school curriculum so if
you donate just a little bit you could
pay for one kid's curriculum for the
foundations of personal finance and uh
yeah even if you donate five bucks just
all that money every single cent of that
is going to go towards uh giving the
kids the money tools they need to start
their lives off right
you want to contribute and get these
ohio schools up and running with the
financial literacy on the minimalist
site just go to ramseysolutions.com
the minimalists or ramseysolutions.com
sponsorship schools slash the minimalist
says to me slashes yeah that first
somewhere in there you're going to get
lost but go in there and we can connect
you up and uh let you make a
contribution it's it's a crowd sourcing
crowd funding process here and uh you
know what we established early on as we
got to know each other was this
tremendous connection between minimalism
and personal finance yeah y'all talk
about that a little bit people people
call into our podcast all the time and
they talk about all the stuff they have
and all the money they don't have
and we're surrounded by things right
what you see here is there's all this
physical clutter and it's really a
physical manifestation of what's going
on inside of us there's a whole lot of
other clutter besides material clutter
right there's financial clutter
we're being irresponsible there's
priority clutter think about this for a
second i was at the airport the other
day i was watching one of the news
screens and there was this terrible
shooting that happened and they
interrupted it with breaking news to
talk about the johnny depp trial
and it seems like that is our priority
with our money as well what is the shiny
thing so in other words that's a little
confused and a lot of people are a
little confused about a lot of stuff
yeah that's just sick right yeah yeah
and so we have we have all of this
additional clutter and it starts with
the stuff but as we start simplifying we
make room for the things that are truly
important and we start to realize like
oh this financial clutter is a result of
my physical clutter i thought i needed
all of these things that were supposed
to make me happy but they're doing the
opposite they're not making me happy
they're making me miserable they're
getting in the way of what's truly
important josh milburn ryan nicodemus
they are the minimalists and we're
trying to work with them and get a bunch
of their team our their tribe our tribe
to
get these into the ohio area schools
ramsey solutions dot com slash the
minimalist again 45 to get a personal
finance for one high school student 4
500 to put 100 through so just whatever
your budget is jump in there part of
this whole process is generosity it fits
in the mix too amen so uh good stuff
thanks for coming by guys love you dave
good luck with the emmy thing i want to
i want to hear about this man all right
man look for us to be thanking you when
we exactly
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today ryan is in las vegas hey
ryan welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
man what's up
hey uh just a good question for you um
my wife and i are in a uh interesting
position we're um we're gonna be
debt-free at the end of this year which
is awesome working off my last uh
student loan at the end of december and
then um situation we find ourselves in
is my father-in-law is uh you know we're
we're pretty confident he has
parkinson's it's
gotten pretty bad he's you know he's got
some money saved for retirement but
there's no life insurance there's no
long-term care insurance and
um i love my mother-in-law to death so
we're just kind of trying to wrap our
brains around
you know what options we might have and
i was listening to you today and i just
thought i'd give you a call and see
if there's anything maybe i haven't
thought of that might be able to help
with the cost because it's you know the
big thing is the care piece of it which
is going to get expensive and if there's
no insurance to cover that
um you know we're just we're just kind
of curious what what options we might
have yeah
if he's got a parkinson's diagnosis
you're not getting long-term care or
life insurance
it's like you can't buy you can't buy
homeowners insurance after the house
burns down
and so
that's um
that's what you're facing there so how
what's the size of the retirement
account
um
my mother-in-law just got power of
attorney uh so she's in control of all
the money and from what we understand
we're thinking it's about a million to a
million and a half um
unfortunately there was no uh following
the baby steps with with the way they
kind of handled money so we're not
really even sure what he has
um we just don't want our mother-in-law
or my mother-in-law to burn through all
that trying to care for care for my
father-in-law well as long as she
manages the budget in the process and
maybe you can help her with that she
will not burn through it
um average nursing home stay is 75 to
100k
and the average time in a nursing home
is 2.8 years
so how how old is your father-in-law
uh he's in his 60s later later half of
the 60s and with the
progression of the disease that i've
seen in the three years i've been with
his daughter it's
i mean it's just progressed so quickly
we don't know how long it's going to be
it's just it's just a weird situation to
be in yeah
so um
the uh
this is horrible i'm so sorry y'all are
facing this it's it's
uh i lost a good friend to this uh about
four or five years ago and i watched him
fight it for about six years and like
you said it just the progression is
it's kind of brutal really i'm so sorry
um so um
yeah i think the way she's got plenty of
money she's okay
all right uh and so just to be very cold
and calculated for a minute i mean he's
probably got a couple three years
i'm not a doc what do you think
ryan
you with me
did i lose him
well we lost something there
lost something there all right let's try
one more time and see if i can yeah he's
gone okay
um all right so uh phone glitch or
something i don't know but
so the problem with these situations is
it takes a highly emotional situation
like a tragedy like a debilitating
disease and it turns it into a uh ryan
are you there
ryan
three two one okay i'm done with that
y'all figure that out um the it takes a
highly debilitating situation
and
the emotional charging of that and
what you've got to guard against is um
allowing in in your uh
well deloney said dr john lennon says in
in the middle of a situation like this
facts are your friends when you're
facing
a uh highly emotional situation facts
are your friends so you got to come down
off the
emotion and step to the side for a
second and have an out-of-body
experience a little bit and look at the
math and the math is he's in his late
60s
highly progressed so i'm guessing i
don't know anything about this i'm just
using observation i'm not a doc and i'm
not saying that he could live 10 years
for all i know but i'm guessing he's not
going to
and so if he goes through
um if he goes through uh
three years of a hundred thousand
dollars a year and they got a million
and a half she's fine
as long as you manage that you don't let
somebody come in and charge you three
hundred thousand dollars a year for care
you know that would be but you can and
that can happen if you don't keep your
wits about you
so the thing that ryan can do for his
mother-in-law is
give her
a sounding board and some accountability
and i'll walk with you
so that together we can all make good
wise decisions and then if they do that
they got plenty of money yeah that was
going to be my question is what should
ryan's role
be in this because it sounds like he is
a little bit worried about his
mother-in-law perhaps burning through
the budget
but i mean should he just volunteer to
help her or what should that look like
as he approaches her uh yeah you just
you know can i please
be your
backup
be your uh
uh you know the person that walks beside
you i love you i love him i obviously
love your daughter and i'll i will walk
with you and we'll use some
you know good we're gonna make sure
dad's taken care of we're gonna make
sure you're taken care of and the way to
do that is to spend the appropriate
amount of money and no more
for his care
the appropriate and no more
because if you do that you're going to
have plenty left over mom
and uh
unless some kind of weird or bizarre
thing happens here that i can't see with
the information i have
but yeah yeah and then this is the the
reason that two things that this this
call reinforces two things one is it's a
really good idea to have some money
when you get to your golden years a mean
and a half changes this equation a lot
if he told me at 150 000 this equation's
a problem
right so that that's a wonderful thing
that they've done they've done a great
job of building some wealth and then the
second thing it does is it says okay if
you're worried about this stuff i think
with a me and a half they're okay
maybe self-insured easy enough but if
you're worried about it you should have
had before this life insurance and
long-term care insurance in place
long-term care insurance if you've got
under a million dollars as far as i'm
concerned is
absolutely vital once you reach 60 years
old and i would not buy before then but
um the cost of nursing home again the
average stay in america is 2.8 years
average cost of 75 to 100 a year
so you add it up it's 250 000 bucks
that's the average which means that some
people are more and some people are less
and you can do in-home care cheaper and
some would argue in some cases that
that's a better quality of care
depending on the
issues that you're dealing with at home
and some people have to do that because
they don't have choice
and make sure somebody gets high quality
care but that that's the uh the process
that we get into
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money so
again people ask about this all the time
let's just recap a little bit the
you can be self-insured if you can
absorb a 250 300 000 blow
and still have enough left for the
remaining spouse to live on that's the
big deal
that's good in ryan's situation it
sounded like so his wife that's her
father how does he navigate both the
emotions of empowering his wife to be
part of these money conversations but
also the emotions of the fact that her
father is going through yeah i think you
just have to say it all out loud yeah
you know it's um
a lot of awkwardness is removed if
someone just has the courage to just say
it
and say you know this really sucks
and my heart is breaking
the only thing that would make my heart
break more
is if we walk out this process in the
wrong way to where mom is not taken care
of
right so we've got to walk this out an
appropriate care for him
making sure all the while that there's
money left for mom
that's so important to highlight because
i think a lot of people feel
uncomfortable on one hand having these
health conversations and the sadness of
it but also money conversations can be
hard and people kind of want to avoid
some of that so it's important to have
both conversations even if it's sticky
if it's hard if it's emotional
these need to happen up front yeah
you know but what i've found is in the
years of doing financial coaching
sometimes everybody in the room knows
something is there and just saying it
out loud takes the power out of it you
know it's like they tell you this whole
story and you go hey did you know that
sounded a little crazy like you're
acting crazy when you say that out loud
everybody goes yeah that is a little
crazy even the crazy person goes yeah
that's a little crazy you know if you
just if you just name it you know it's
like this sucks it hurts i'm scared
i love everybody it makes me want to cry
every time i think about it and it's
horrible
and we're going to do it together
because we love each other and this is
called family and when you just say it
out loud it lets the it takes some of
the power out of it it's all the bottled
up that gives it so much power
and it's still going to be a hard
process
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage dylan and brie
are with us
uh from sanford maine
welcome guys good to have y'all
hey how's it going where is sanford
maine it's right outside of portland oh
okay all right ll bean country then yeah
yeah very cool well good to have you
guys welcome to nashville and all the
way down here to the south to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off 188 thousand one hundred dollars
how long did that take 34 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time we got married we started
around 90 and then last year we ended up
at 195. whoa what do you all do for a
living i'm a biochemist
and i'm a machinist for a big airplane
company good very cool and you guys have
been busting it then huh sure have yeah
very good how long you been married
three years okay so this whole thing
starts when you get married 34 months
and you knock out 188 000 of what what
kind of debt that was our mortgage you
paid off your house yes first thing we
do we get married to pay off our house
this is this is just weird that's just
amazing how old are you two
i'm 26 and i'm 25 with a paid for house
what's this house worth about 350. y'all
are amazing you're so weird i love you
that's awesome way to go you guys
absolutely killer
very very good great stuff
great stuff life is good what gave you
the inspiration to do this tell us the
back story here so it all started on my
18th birthday my uncle gave me one of
your books
and it sat on my bookshelf for about a
year
and then i finally decided it gives an
18 year old dave ramsey i mean come on
that's like giving you socks for
christmas
and then after i read it i was hooked i
am
a planner so i thought that was a great
plan so i decided to get my then
boyfriend dylan at the time to go to
financial peace university with me oh
and i did drag him there yes um he was
not very excited no
but but you were exciting so he got you
that's a good plan good job dylan yeah i
showed up so yeah yeah and then what
happened when you get to class dylan
uh took about what four or five weeks
until i really liked it about halfway
through the class and then i got
got um on the plan and paid off the
truck paid off the motorcycle and
um she paid off some some of her loans
and
um so when you get married you were
debt-free yeah absolutely and then we
bought a house and said we're knocking
it out now well we originally planned to
buy the house and pay it off in about
seven or eight years which is the
average when you're on dave's plan yeah
and um
fortunately unfortunately cove it
happened and uh we couldn't do anything
oh
we were supposed to go in the ram to
cruise and then unfortunately that got
cancelled shh don't tell anybody
um so we took the money from the crews
and we put it on the mortgage and we saw
the amount of the mortgage go down
um
pretty pretty drastically wow and uh it
got us fired up we were like paid off
yeah it ended up working out for us
we're a little bummed so we have to do
another one okay so so if we book
another one you'll go absolutely yeah
really you're you're willing to go back
out there on the house look at today
dave with uh with the pandemic in the
background you're willing to go i don't
know if i'm willing to do this again it
was pretty painful for me we'll drag you
just like bree dragged me to fpu
i'll be straight with you i was drug
into the first one but it worked really
well until the pandemic took it out and
then it became a pr disaster but oh wow
way to go guys i'm so proud of y'all so
what did the journey look for like for
y'all you guys had a huge income jump
but what all did you all do to get out
of debt
i worked seven days a week for the last
year and a half uh 10 plus day 10 plus
hours a week a day i'm sorry i think
80 hours a week for a year and a half
and brie stayed home and cooked and
cleaned and saved this money from the
groceries front well i also had a
full-time job as well
so i was working 40 hours a week and
then i would come home cook dinner clean
the house make sure everything was all
set for when dylan came home from his
shift all he had to worry about was
eating and going to bed and doing it
again exactly and so that was kind of
the way that we had divided the workload
so it didn't make sense for me to do
overtime at the time made more sense for
him and so that's what we did um we
but you both thought you were both in
agreement to this ridiculous schedule
yeah for a short period of time because
it knocks it out and some of the drastic
things we did i really tightened up our
grocery budget i got it to about 20
a week and so good lore i was couponing
and really eating pinching pennies we
didn't eat terribly we ate very well
dave we
bought all of our meat meat in bulk and
uh we've been to the store and bought
veggies every week and about 20 30 hours
a week lobster is cheap in that area but
yeah not that cheap
wow amazing you guys you guys are fun so
what do you do now
i mean you're 100 debt free you make
like 150 200 000 a year
i cut the overtime down yeah so now
we're making about 150. yeah
it's put us in a spot where free has
been able to leave her job and go to
another job took a little pay cut but
it's a job that she's happier with
and so we're just going to scale back on
the working and do more traveling and
be together more is there a certain big
single thing you wanted to do now that
you're free
i guess the the big goal in the end was
paying off the mortgage will help me one
day become a stay-at-home mom and that
was our long-term goal um without having
a house payment it makes living on one
income so much easier so much less
stressful we can still save money and so
that was really the the big long-term
goal until that point comes really just
traveling and enjoying spending time
yeah we need to get that ramsey cruise
up so that you don't get a babysitter
yeah yeah okay
get it going fast all right way to go
you guys you're impressive who are your
biggest cheerleaders
we kept it mostly a secret we had a
couple friends that i work with and a
couple family members that knew about it
um but mostly it was just the two of us
keeping each other going that was going
to be my next question is that you know
you guys are 25 and 26 paying off your
house at any age is not normal but doing
it at 25 and 26 that's really weird and
awesome yeah what would you tell people
that are in your generation that are
young who think like ah no i'm gonna
keep student loans forever paying off a
house that's strange like what would you
tell them to break through and help them
believe that it's possible
i think what i would like to say while
we were getting through this is i became
or we both became comfortable with being
uncomfortable and really you know
pinching pennies and
and making hard decisions and you know i
remember sometimes i'd look at the clock
and you know it's eight o'clock and
dylan's still not home from work and he
left you know at five o'clock in the
morning and so really
learning that these short-term
sacrifices will give you so much more in
the end and that all of the pain that
you go through and and the hardships are
really are really worth it
i mean when you get an agreement about
that and neither one of you is whining
about the process it changes the whole
formula yeah i mean if you'd been
whining about the work or she'd been
whining about you my new husband's gone
all the time you know instead we're like
game on game on it's just for a short
period of time we're gonna live like no
one else so later we can live and give
like no one else you were like grown-ups
and stuff way to go y'all wow so
impressive very cool i'm proud of you
it's very very good it's amazing
absolutely amazing you're a sharp couple
you're going to go big go big we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that is definitely the next chapter in
your story no doubt about it you're on
the way to do that and i got a feeling
you're going to do some really cool
things with money in your life it's
going to be a great tool in your hands
you'll be master of it instead of the
other way around got a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away and
get somebody started uh once you start
telling the story a little bit people
are going to know how you did that and a
financial peace university won your
membership as well we'll put you in that
and or you can give that away if you
want to whatever you want to do what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is the key main thing for us for
me anyway it was communication um we
talked about everything if we bought
something we talked about it first
um and that got us on the same page with
money and actually a lot of other things
too
brought us closer together
and so that was the key for me you know
just talking about everything financial
going through financial peace university
really taught us how to communicate
really well as a couple and you know
something you bring up in financial
peace university is the amount of money
fights and marriages and we can stand
here today and confidently say we've
never had a money fight yeah um and so
that's what you got him past the fourth
lesson yes yes
kicking and screaming of the first
lesson i was okay yeah that's great you
guys are awesome congratulations dylan
and brie from
maine and 188 000 paid off house and
everything in 34 months lots of hard
work count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're different
[Applause]
well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five paul is in new
york city hey paul how are you
i'm good thank you dave how are you
doing better than i deserve how can we
help
okay so
um
we have a bit of a interesting situation
um the last two years have been
dreadful i heard the room
and um
we have uh we have two
rental properties
my wife and i both work
and one of them was flooded back in
september
it's located in a non-flood zone so we
don't have any we didn't have any flood
insurance on it so we had to pay
everything out of pocket so i zeroed out
a lot of our savings
uh in order to keep everything afloat
pay the mortgage et cetera
with a flood yeah okay
exactly and the uh and you know uh i
live in new york so
uh we had the eviction moratorium so
they stopped paying and i couldn't even
do anything with it so
it was just a horrible horrible mess so
we finally got a sale
we are under contract
uh and my wife and i were sort of at uh
different ends of the spectrum with she
wants to do a 1031 exchange and go into
more brio say i want to be a seller in
this environment i don't want to be a
buyer
i don't think i want to wait at least
for some prices to come down and i'd
rather pay off some small debts that we
have and sort of
take the rest of the cash and just put
it put it away and put it aside
so that's that's what's your householder
i
i
mine is like a little bit north of 100
she's around 90 95 or so what's she
doing
she is a
um
project manager what do you do for a
living
and i am i work in utilities so i'm an
engineer
okay
all right
so um
some of this is a personality style
uh you're you're an engineer you're a
detail guy and the overwhelming number
of details and the crisis has gotten to
you more than it did to her
um
and that's okay that's the way just the
way it is um
and so what you guys just need to
recognize is i'm gonna send you a copy
of rachel cruz's book i want both of you
to read it's called know yourself know
your money
because a lot of what's happening here
is not that a 1031 is right or wrong
or not that taking some time off from
this market is right or wrong
either one is actually okay
as a matter of fact but it's not okay
that you're not that you can't get on
the same page and that um that she's not
hearing the amount of stress in your
voice that i'm hearing
this has worn you out dude
yeah i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm just i'm you're
bleeding you're bleeding you're wounded
i i've been we have been bleeding i know
you're a wounded warrior right now
yeah
and you're bleeding emotionally i can
hear it i feel it talking to you
okay and i'm not i'm not i'm not saying
you're weak i'm just saying that's a
reality there's times in my life i got
the crap knocked out of me and i was
bleeding too so i mean that's just life
you just need to recognize that and then
she needs to recognize that too
and not be such a player right now this
is a good time for y'all to pull back
and heal so i'm going to actually take
your side but not because you're right
but just because you need to be together
and you both need to be doing stuff from
strength not when one of you is pulling
the other one along from weakness
what other debts do you have
we have
um
we have the the mortgage
on our primary residence we have another
rental property but that's paid for by
the
by the rents no it's not paid for by the
renter as you noticed if they don't pay
you can't get them out you still have to
pay stinking payment that's mythology
absolutely that's mythology and then we
have this other mortgage um but it's you
know we're under contract so yeah and
you don't have any personal debt at all
um no not real a personal debt i mean i
have uh i have like a a small credit
card that's around 8k she has another
credit small credit card that's around
what do you owe on your mortgage
uh
for
something for twenty four what are you
getting out of this sale this rental
net profit
net profit after after every after all
said and done probably like 200 250
something like that all right
see i want you guys to have some peace
you haven't had peace in a while
that's why i wrote a book called
financial peace two words that don't go
together like airline service
right
and so you guys are you just you cannot
you cannot run with no
emotional margin in your personal
finances and win long term
now i'm more like your wife my wife is
more like you paul on the other hand
she's like slow down
we got time it's gonna be okay i don't
feel like doing this right now i'm kind
of wounded and i'm like game on warrior
mode
you know and so i'm more like your wife
but i can i can hear it in your voice
and from years of doing what i do
i've learned actually to have a little
bit of empathy a tiny bit but a little
bit
the the thing all the the thing that
stresses me out is that i mean the 1031
is great because you know you defer the
taxes and whatnot but the you know it's
a 45-day window
no the whole freaking thing of owning
rental property and being back in debt
and dealing with the tenant after you
just went through everything you went
through stresses you out
you went out of the real estate business
at least a little bit
calm down a little bit it's all she
needs to do it's okay i would not do a
1031 i would just sideline this money
for right now
you don't want to jump back in you said
you don't want to jump back into this
market right now while it's quite still
hot
it's still hot and i i want to be a
seller i don't want to be a buyer
exactly
and there's a lot of reasons for that
some of them mo are just legitimate
emotions
trauma
small t trauma i mean you know brain
damage you didn't get you know you
didn't almost die or something but you
just been through crap
and a lot of people have in this season
you know we've been through all kinds of
stuff with covet and inflation and i
mean i had a little trauma when i filled
up my truck
i mean you mentioned that that's funny
that you mentioned that because two to
two uh what was it a couple of months
prior to this i actually went in for
brain surgery whoa
yeah are you okay yeah no i mean it's a
recurring thing i have um
i have a condition from my childhood
year so i have to go back every every so
often for uh revisions and repairs yeah
bad choice of metaphor then sorry okay
no no it's okay i don't know but no
no i know so i i do think that you have
to here's the thing
uh personal finance is also personal and
you have to take into consideration
what's going on in your life
brain surgery floods bad tenants
moratoriums during pandemic
this has all left its mark on you
and your wife again
her answer is not wrong i'm actually
personally doing a 1031 right now so
it's not wrong okay
but but it but but i got zero stress
over it i'm not it's not putting
it's not it's not activating me the way
you're being activated with this and so
i think you just chill a little bit
let's pull back i might i might even
throw the money at your mortgage and
start thinking about how fast we pay off
a mortgage making 200 a year yeah that's
my thought is just how much less stress
they would have if they you know
followed the baby steps and worked
through paying off the mortgage and then
once they hit baby step seven invest in
real estate and do it with cash that'll
just feel or if the other mortgage on
the rental is like 200 reach over and
just pay it off
on that other mortgage and then you just
have your own only debt would be your
home mortgage get really stupid credit
cards let's get on a plan
that's so good steady
wise
and and
what happens is when we get we get all
frenetic and get in a hurry and
i do it too
i'm the world's worst because i'm so
freaking task oriented but um but i i'm
you know i'm the guy that doesn't need
to be telling anybody else about this
but i the truth is i can i can just
smell it on him you can feel in the air
can't you oh you can feel it my heart
feels like it's like in a knot just
listening to his voice and like you can
feel the stress yeah and that's not
weakness
that's just saying this is reality it's
not it's not you know if you had
brain surgery
you know and you had
you know reality is it just leaves a
wound and it takes a little give
yourself a little room you'll make
better decisions you'll make better
choices when you're not as
wired and spun up in the whole process
and
i'm i'm gonna take your side but not for
the not for the reasons you presented
but instead just saying you just don't
need rental property right now you
already got one that's probably one too
many
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books uh good job miss christina
austin ben zach andrew james kelly in
the booth good work i am dave ramsey
your host
and we'll be back
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth
do work that they love and that matters
create actual amazing relationships
joining me today is my co-host here on
the ramsey show is ramsey personality
best-selling author christina ellis as
we answer your questions about your life
and your money open phones here at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're gonna start this hour with
portland oregon rebecca is with us hi
rebecca how are you
hi i'm doing great thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
all right are you sitting down this is a
big one dave
okay so my husband is a dentist i'm a
nurse practitioner our annual income is
about 330 000 a year
in 2020 i opened up my own practice with
zero debt because i'm extremely dead
adverse i drink your kool-aid although
i'm not good at following through i wish
i was better um but we'll get there so
um obviously starting out the practice
didn't have a lot of income with that so
we really were relying on my husband's
income
but now i'm starting to bring in an
income for our family so our house
payment is 2800 a month we have over 500
000 in student loans
we have no other debt we've already paid
off over just a hundred thousand but it
has taken us four years to get to this
point we were hoping that by four to
five years after my husband graduated
we'd have it all paid off
but like i said we're not so great with
the the follow through so here's the
deal my husband let me stop tell me a
second let me ask you one clarifying
question okay your practice is now
taking off what does your husband make
so my husband makes we were looking back
how will he make this year will he make
it in a year this year
what are you gonna make this year 330 is
what we're thinking okay and what are
you gonna make now that the practice is
moving
well i'm hoping right now i've been
bringing home consistently for about the
last three months between two to five k
depending on i just go off of a
percentage of my what do you think
you're gonna make in the year
what do i think i will i'm going to make
a hundred thousand i think you will
and then the next year you're going to
make 150.
uh yes 100 yeah okay that's realistic
okay so you have a 430 000 income
in 2022.
yeah you've never had that before
never so we don't need to throw you
under the bus so much for not following
through in the past maybe a little but
not so much
okay okay i mean you you never really
had an income above 200 but much before
this year right no
never so your income's legitimately
doubled this year
legitimate yeah okay good you guys are
that's that's
the good news is you have a really big
shovel while you have a really big hole
but here's here's the kicker dave i need
this advice because my husband and i are
on different um aspects of this so he
wants to buy into his practice and
you're only going to buy
people you don't buy into practice when
you're broke people
okay thank you absolutely not it's
unwise it's not just a dave ramsey thing
it's just it's financially unwise you
can't walk around with your head in the
clouds acting like you have a half
million dollars in student loan debt act
like you don't have any debt
this is a dentist disease
i swear to god of all the doctors i work
with dentists go into more debt than all
of them put together
they go for because for some reason a
dental degree is more i don't even
understand that it is but i mean i meet
a lot of dentists that are 300 to 400 in
student loan debt and then they want to
go another three to 500 in and buy into
a practice or build a practice from
scratch
and go buy all the equipment one of the
two and try to do it all the same time
and walk around acting like where do
they teach you in dental school that a
million dollars is a great thing to be
in debt amount no
no
no no no no you've got time
but you need to lay a foundation
you're going to be very very wealthy if
you do this right or you're going to be
walking around with debt hanging around
your neck with a level of stress
that you can't even breathe for the next
decade because you just won't say no to
yourself
right
i feel yeah i i mean i you can tell
there's two types of dentists out there
when it comes to our material
ones that love me and ones that hate me
there is no middle ground
yeah because the typical model is what
your husband's laying out what he's
going right down the dental school
template
all of his buddies are doing the same
stupid butt stuff he's trying to do
he's pointing out to me right now that
he wants me to share with you that his
income's going to increase to 500 2 000
the loan payment's 146 he'll make 357 a
year and that's an extra 37 000 a year
that he'll be bringing home after he
buys into the practice yeah if he
doesn't get sick or there's not a
pandemic or one of the partners doesn't
commit a crime and blow the whole thing
up
right
the only way his crap works is if
everything works and you know when
everything works in this world never
never
it's a freaking optimistic i appreciate
optimism but that amount of debt is
beyond optimism it's fantasy land
so he can buy into the practice later or
he can buy into another practice one
thing about dennis is there's always one
for sale
you can always get another one it's like
financial planners with a book of
business you're they're always you can
always get a book of business they're
out there and if he can't buy into this
practice he can buy into another one
later please don't do this please please
please please please please please
listen here's the thing
the reason i'm saying all this is not
just because of debt or something like
that the reason the bottom line reason
this whole thing is
i truly believe after 30 years of doing
this and obviously coaching a whole
bunch of dentists in the process
um that that
10 years from today you will be
wealthier following what i'm telling you
to do
than following what he's talking about
i really do believe that because i don't
think he's factoring in any kind of risk
in his equations
and the only way his stuff works is if
it works perfectly and it never works
perfectly
i mean you've got you've got crazy
people in washington dc you've got crazy
people in the medical community oh sorry
you got crazy people and you know i mean
out here with the coping like coveted
stuff and you know you just don't know
what suddenly we're just going to change
the way business is done in america why
we just decided to no i this scares the
crud out of me it just no i'm thank you
i'm so thankful you were not think about
it think about if you were in this and
how much dentistry went on during covid
none nine for three months we know yeah
and you know what would have happened oh
my god y'all are acting like you didn't
just come through that i'm just
wondering can this be like a three to
five year goal yeah i mean like well
here's the thing you ought to be debt
free in two years right because i'm like
a 430 000 income you guys could live on
100k and still have 330. to put towards
come on lower your freaking lifestyle
stay home
and work and knock this debt out in two
years you should be debt-free and then
save up and pay cash i don't want to
hear about a loan for buying into the
practice just pay cash to buy into the
practice
okay that could happen in five years
that's not a very long trajectory and if
these guys don't want to wait and they
think you've lost your mind then you
probably have the wrong partners anyway
because they're all going to be in debt
up to their eyeballs and run the thing
into the dirt
so
uh dentistry is it's
um
it's as unpredictable as any other
business or industry right now
so no please don't do that i'm afraid i
can't talk him out of it but she was
already talked out of what she called
she just wanted she's weaponizing the
ramsay show but
it's all right that's right we we have
we have to be good for something around
here
weapons weapons we can do hey i think
they can get there go give yourself some
time
save up do it fifty thousand dollars a
year in debt reduction i mean who can do
that you can do that nobody else can do
that and you can be done in two freaking
years
first world problems this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
well the housing market is out of
control out there
kind of crazy
and rates are going nuts and
people don't know whether to buy or sell
we have people saying i'm not going to
buy more prices go down i got news for
you honey prices aren't coming down
there's too big a shortage of supply
and even with rates going up even with
the economy slowing even with uh what
may be some stagflation some inflation
operating during a recession
it doesn't matter you're still going to
see a shortage of supply and housing and
so we're going to see
price increases slow but we're not going
to see this go away it's not going to
have a dip like it had in 2008 we've had
one time since the great depression that
house prices went backward one time
one time that was through 2008 and this
is not gonna be one of those times
so don't be waiting to buy a house if
you're thinking about buying a house and
you're ready
and you have the money and you're not in
debt and you're buying the right price
range and you can afford it and all that
kind of stuff
waiting on house prices to go down is
not a good idea because five years from
now they'll be up
a year from now they'll be up just not
as much as they were the last two years
so get in there if you want to learn
more about all this stuff go to ramsey
trusted real estate
and you can find it all out ramsey
solutions.com
agent get with a good real estate agent
in your area and they'll teach you what
i'm talking about
so christina we were talking earlier
today
i think we're going to do i'll announce
it officially after we get it all
figured out but i think we're going to
do a um
a quick stand up we're just going to
stand up and do a a quick uh streaming
event free streaming event for uh talk
about the real estate market
uh just because so many people are so
concerned about it right now everybody's
freaking out and we need to just kind of
put the facts out there here's what
housing starts are here's what they were
at the high point here's that they're a
fourth of what they were
and the
you know
populations continued to grow and
everything else but i want to sidebar
that for a second and we'll come back to
it we'll let you guys know when we're
getting ready to do that it'll be
probably a month or so but there's a lot
of people talking about it a lot of bad
information about real estate a lot of
fear out there
about whether i'll ever get a house and
all that kind of stuff right now and we
got to kind of get in there and talk
about all that and what when what's the
right way to do it everybody calm down
but let's change gears i'm going to go
back to that last call
a hundred percent of the time
the advice that we give you here
is based on
common sense
biblical truth
and data
people that we know that have built
wealth
and
what we're always looking for that we
want to lead you to
is the shortest
right way
from where you are today
to becoming wealthy
now the lie that has been told is is
that you can borrow your way into
prosperity
and the whole culture has believed that
and the whole culture's broke
you can't borrow your way into
prosperity it doesn't work
instead your most powerful wealth
building tool
until you have about five million
dollars
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income
what you earn
it gives you the power to build wealth
and when you give that all away to
someone else in the form of debt whether
it's a half a million dollars in dental
school bills or uh she was pa so someone
was probably on her pa school debt
whatever it is or whether it's twenty
thousand dollars in
student loan debt or whether it's um an
80 000 a car that you had to have a
tesla or whatever the stupid butt thing
you did was that's got debt on it then
you've given up the mol you've given up
the power of your income because you've
given it to someone else now they're
getting wealthy with your money
and
thus you notice the towers in the
skyline of every city are what
banks and life insurance companies
it's hardly anything else there some
hotels nowadays because you're giving
them your money too but that's about it
you know i mean you go into most major
cities that's the
the skyline was comprised of people
giving away their livelihood
to someone else to get this and so
one of the things you learned when you
were going through
in high school and your mom sat down and
said we don't need money
if you want to go to school you need
scholarships you learn to delay pleasure
to give
because you're going to pay a price
you're either going to be in pain now or
you're going to live in the pain of
mediocrity later
yep i my mom basically said you're on
your own you got to figure it out she
loved me she wanted to challenge me to
figure it out but you know she's like
you got to work hard now and i spent a
lot of my time in high school just
hustling building up a resume to try to
win scholarships and stand out in the
application process and in college i
worked a lot i missed out on a lot of
parties i had to really spend extra
hours in the library studying you know
off hours when other people were having
fun but it would have been easy to just
go
hey
i mean we
might i have a single mom
we're going to be money i want to go to
school there's only one way i can do
this i was
forced
is the language people use
to go into student loan debt because it
was the only
way
now that would have been easy
that would have been easy but later it
would have been hard because then you
have a phone call like we just took
where you got to pay back yeah short
term easy long term hard yeah yeah
easy's always hard yeah definitely i
mean it's paid off so much in the long
run because yes there was that season of
sacrifice but now i graduated without
debt so hard is always easy oh
there we go there we go you're gonna pay
a price to win just decide what the
price is hard now
is easy later for the rest of your life
or easy now is hard later yep so easy's
hard hard's easy well that's what i try
to tell students with student loan debt
i think that a lot of students just
think oh like this is the way to go and
somehow magically poof it's going to
resolve itself down the road and it's
like no no no this may be easy now but
this is going to be real
income going to these payments later
down the road this is going to be hard
it turns out aoc is not the student loan
ferry who knew you know poof it goes
away it's not going away people it's
still there and you're still going to
end up paying it and it's still a
problem
so yeah you're either in in money stuff
and in most of life really
if you want a high quality long-term
result
it's seldom easy at the start it's
usually hard at the start
hard is easy
and if you want a low quality long-term
result go ahead and go woohoo i'm gonna
yolo you only live life once baby
friday
thank god it's friday
oh god it's monday
and you look up living your life like an
emotional five-year-old and 25 years
later you're 50 and you're still a
freaking juvenile
because you're still living with the
emotional maturity of a child
children do what feels good adults
devise a plan and follow it
hard
is the easiest path right well if you
look back at my story so it seemed hard
in high school oh man this stinks to
miss a party man this stinks to spend
extra hours filling out scholarship
applications but when i look back my
average i went over half a million
dollars in scholarship so i was making
like 500 an hour which it's like in the
long run
like what other job can you get in high
school making that much money and so
it's like yes it felt hard but in
hindsight that was super easy compared
to
giving away my money to pay off interest
down the road so it definitely paid off
here's the thing it paid off it paid off
in in lots of ways because you become
through that process
this impressive
woman that you are
and then you walk in here and we go hey
we want that lady is to be part of the
ramsay thing yeah and but if you came in
here and went uh well you know i just i
just believe in student loans and i'm
just going to keep them around like
they're a freaking pet you wouldn't be
sitting here
you know so because of who you became
through that process now you're now
you're doing this that wouldn't have
been open to you it wouldn't have come
up because you know we've not hired a
ramsey personality that you know what
are you in charge of losing no i don't
really we don't need one of those we
don't you know what's your specialty i
lose all the time no i don't need one of
those i need people to inspire people to
be better and bigger and and do half a
million dollars with a best-selling book
before you came here that's what you
become but you became that because of
the hard
not because of the easy
hard is easy easy's hard when i love
seeing
the young generation doing that we had a
debt-free scream earlier 25 and 26 year
olds yeah hang off their house living on
20
a week for groceries like you know that
is hard you know what that dentist needs
to do he needs to pay them 50 000 a year
to come live with him and coach him only
that'd be such a pay cut for them they
couldn't afford the pay cut they could
afford it but they wouldn't take the pay
cut because they're making more than the
dentist oh my god
wow
easy's hard hard's easy
you have to learn the magic word the
ancient word it has great power
no
it's a great word
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage scott
and lauren are with us hey guys how are
you hi good how are you for having us
better than i deserve welcome where do
you all live we live in lansing michigan
oh fun welcome to nashville thank you
and all the way down here to do a
debt-free scream how much did you pay
off we paid off 101
190
all right and how long did this take two
and a half years good for you
and your range of income during that
time uh we started around 83 000 and
then ended around 97. good what do y'all
do for a living i'm a sixth grade uh
math and science teacher good for you a
geospatial analyst at the local
interviewer university oh okay very good
good for y'all okay so 101 000 of what
what kind of debt was this so eleven
thousand was one car about fifteen
thousand was another and then seventy
five thousand in student loans that were
just kind of normal yeah how long you
been married uh almost three years okay
very good so not long after you get
married you said okay something's gotta
change tell me the story what happened
yeah so um basically
we'd already always kind of talked about
our finances when we were dating and i
knew a little bit about um you know the
debt and stuff the student loans are
scots so
we we kind of figured that out um once
we started dating
yeah they're gone yes they are gone they
are gone
so once we started getting serious about
um you know getting engaged and talking
about marriage we
sat down and started really looking at
the numbers um of what we had to do and
i um grew up my family has been familiar
with you and we've listened to your show
on like long car rides and things like
that so
i was always familiar with dave ramsey
and then scott would drive home from
work
before we were married and he would like
call me and say hey i've listened to
this guy on the radio and i'm like yeah
i know who that is
but then we started talking about
exactly when we wanted to start this so
we got engaged and really hashed out a
plan and then after we got married we
really you know kicked butt on it see
scott this is what happens when you
marry math teachers right you made a
good choice this is exactly what
happened i might be the nerd she might
have a plan
she might have a plan and she might tell
you what your plan is
i like it that's awesome you guys thank
you and so you sat down mapped out a
plan together i'm joking around but
y'all did this together yeah and you
both said okay seventy five thousand and
fifteen thousand and eleven thousands
gotta go
yep okay cool so looking at how much you
all make compared to how much you paid
off you all were pretty aggressive with
your budget what
what did the journey look like for y'all
what did you do to get out of debt um we
we definitely used the every dollar
budget app and that was really helpful i
was a little apprehensive a bit of it at
first
i liked things on paper and i was like
well i don't want to use the online one
i want to look at it on paper but got
used to that took us a few months to
really see and
um when when we started um out we we
were just wasting money and we figured
out how much we were just throwing away
at you know going out to eat or
just getting extra stuff at the grocery
store that we really didn't need or
didn't use so um once we looked at our
plan and looked how much extra we had
we figured out how much we could really
throw at the debt and how much we could
really live on when you lay out a budget
you always go where's all that going
yeah you feel like you got a raise yeah
yeah and i did after school tutoring um
and ran like an after-school science
club what are you getting an hour for
after-school tutoring
um it depends sometimes like 20 or 30 an
hour so yeah i did a few of those and
then
yeah i do it dude during the summer too
so
and then scott was coach basketball on
side yeah that's a good gig yeah so we'd
go to basketball games and then i'd
tutor and do all the things in between
wow very good what was the hardest part
of your journey
i think it was probably like last year
we when the housing market went crazy
and you know everyone was saying oh my
gosh let's buy a house and um we kind of
thought we needed to do that we we've
been in a rental and
we had a baby on the way so we're
thinking okay well everyone else is
getting houses you know we should
probably look at getting a house and we
almost we almost went there and then we
said no we
we refocused and said this is what we
want to do
we want to pay off our debt and we did
that and did it before our deadline that
we had even originally had so and you'll
get a house yeah we will yeah and we're
not worried about it now but at the time
it felt like something we needed to do
everybody around us was doing it
you know all our friends and stuff were
buying houses or talking about buying
houses and asking us when we'd get a
house and um so it was just saying no to
a lot of that and no two vacations or
new cars and other other stuff that we
saw people doing so
such a powerful world for no just being
able to say no with all the temptation
no well yeah
a big reason and you could see the end
you can see the light at the end of the
tunnel and it's not an oncoming train
right there's a way to do this we're
going to knock this out and then we'll
be free we've got the rest of our lives
and once you get that down inside of you
you don't quit no yeah the people that
quit are the ones that don't have big
enough vision
and then they quit and they don't they
don't play all the way through you guys
are impressive thank you thank you very
cool couple very proud of y'all who are
your biggest cheerleaders um definitely
our families um like i said my family
was familiar with dave ramsey so
they would check in with us along the
way they knew we were on the dave ramsey
plan and
do we might not do all the same things
or want to go out to eat a lot or things
like that but they really understood and
would check in on us um so that was
really helpful and my friend phil we
would uh catch up he was on that free
journey as well so we just keep tracking
each other how we're doing and then keep
on giving each other motivation in the
way have a little private club of
encouragement yeah that's good yeah
definitely yeah because all the other
guys around you are nuts yeah like we're
doing this we're doing this yeah it was
like that yeah that's exactly how it is
yeah very cool way to go you guys way to
go what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is um i think being
persistent um and like i said we we
almost stopped last year we almost
thought we needed to stop and get a
house but looking at your goals and
being on the same page with our goals
and having those motivators like looking
at i made like little visuals for us
like hey let's cross off these little
graduation caps every now and then for
um keeping track of the student loans
going away um so just anything that you
need to do to stay motivated um
do it if it's little treats or like
little you know free date nights or
something like that do whatever you got
to do to stay motivated every now and
then you guys are how old
i'm 28 i'm 29. you make 100 000 a year
now and you don't have a payment in the
world no yeah that's pretty cool that's
what it is you're so proud of you how's
it feel it feels really good yeah very
good it feels nice going into the next
step now looking for a house that we can
we can really do it without worrying
about numbers
with wisdom and you don't feel like you
don't feel like you know
like you're going to wake up with a
financial hangover after you do the
house exactly yeah you're going to have
a regret on that
ugly taste on the back of your tongue
yeah
very cool stuff
all right we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you for sure that's the
next chapter in your story and we've got
a copy of total money makeover for you
to give away to someone that you add to
the secret club that'd be good and a
financial peace university um one year
scholarship to that as well one year
membership to that and you can either go
through that yourselves and finish up
your journey or you can send someone
through it that you know and love and uh
all right are we going to put uh the
younger youngster into the uh i think
into the debt-free scream all right good
how old is she
yeah she's 10 months 10 months what's
her name lucy all right lucy you have no
idea how big a hero your parents are
what she has done for what they've done
for you kiddo they've really changed
your life and she didn't even know it
very cool stuff all right scott lauren
and lucy lansing michigan 101 000 paid
off in two and a half years making 83-97
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three
two one we're free
[Applause]
[Music]
you have no idea
i mean
rachel was that size when we filed
bankruptcy
and decided we were going to live like
this and then she walks in here at the
commercial break and stirring up trouble
so i mean you know it's just
it's a it's a family gift but the uh
yeah but the you know i mean it's that
she always says when she sees these she
goes i was that little kid
you changed your family tree you know
you changed your family tree it's so
cool and folks you can do this stuff
yeah that's amazing seeing that
beautiful little face out there y'all
are amazing
she's got great parents yeah good stuff
good stuff life is good
life is good
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 24 16 the
righteous false seven times they rise
again
but the wicked stumble when calamity
strikes
peter marshall said we long for life
without difficulties
remind us that oaks grow strong in
contrary winds
and diamonds are made under pressure
hard is easy
easy's hard
there it is
we all kind of know this but it's human
nature to always want the shortest
easiest path and that's okay
to have that desire but don't let that
desire cause you to go for a shortcut
because the old saying is there is no
shortcut to any place that's worth going
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones here at triple
eight eight two five
two quentin is with us in south bend
indiana hi quentin how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
how can i help
all righty so um i
have a 13 000
car loan
and i've been dating my girlfriend for
about four years now um and we're
looking to
proceed with the future and like
um
start our marriage you know cool how old
are you
[Music]
i'm 18 right now
she's been dating since you were 14
yes sir wow
okay
some middle school love affair i love it
oh yeah cool so are you both out of out
of high school now
uh yes sir yep graduated last year cool
what do you do for a living sir
um i work at a stair company it's called
view rail i make stairs what do you make
what kind of money are you're making
um about 25 an hour so 50
a little bit under 50
a year good for you okay so you're
working hard
yes sir okay so you're thinking about
popping the question after all these
years
correct yes um so with that loan
i am on baby step two
um but i'm throwing all my money towards
my car loan yeah um but i also want to
save for um that question i'm
um looking we're looking
about a year and a half yeah um
so i was just wondering what what do you
think the best is if i just keep
throwing money towards you
you live at home um i actually own a
house i have two roommates renting out
for me they're paying my mortgage
you own a house
yes sir wow
what's the house worth
uh right now
it's probably worth 175.
180.
you're doing all right
well done yeah all right yeah ahead of
the game
and what does she do for a
living i'm sorry what was that what does
she do for a living
she works at the factory at a factory
what'd she make
um about 1500 a week okay good all right
well um
so rule of thumb on engagement rings is
the jewelry store at the mall will tell
you three months of your income
i'm gonna tell you this three months too
much
or two months too much i would back it
down to one month of your income max
so in your case three or four thousand
bucks
okay okay max
and um um
and you obviously are a guy who uh
studies things and develops a plan
you're way ahead of the curve at 18
years old the questions you're asking
the way you're asking them so do the
same thing with diamonds go ahead and
learn about them a little bit
uh talk to several different people in
the business
if you can find a an older friend in
particular that knows a little something
about diamonds that can help you
diamonds are one of the most overpriced
things in retail
you can buy them for half of what you
can
pay them pay
at a store two doors down if you go to a
broker versus a full retail
establishment um and so
but you need to learn what you're
getting and not overpay for a bunch of
hoopla because they do not go up in
value
i bought a bunch of them my wife has too
many of them and they don't go up in
value they just make a good birthday
present that's all
and so you're not you're not making an
investment and there's no correlation
between the size of the diamond and the
success of the marriage as a matter of
fact there may be an inverse correlation
so um
meaning that too big a rock could mean
awful things but yeah um so anyway are
you thinking you said a year and a half
are you saying a year and a half till
the debts paid off or until you propose
uh that's when we want to get married so
i think we're planning on
getting engaged this year
and having our wedding uh next year
who's paying the wedding
um
so i know her parents are gonna throw a
lot of money towards it um my parents
will throw about five thousand
and uh so i'm not sure how much out of
pocket i would need to be you're not
you're not gonna put anything out of
pocket if you got five from one and the
other one's throwing some money at it
you're gonna be fine that's your wedding
make that the budget and that'll be
enough
and you but if i were in your shoes what
i would do is stop paying extra on your
car
for a couple months and save up three or
four grand and then start going diamond
shop and then get back on the business
and knock on your car debt out as soon
as possible
okay um and don't ever borrow money on a
car again
yeah i know all right yeah i know you
knew before you did it too but you did
it anyway yes yes sir i did
my other question is i have about um
four grand of my name and my bank
account that i was waiting to throw in
my car but i have uh my real estate test
coming up this
saturday
um
and i know their starting fees up for
that it's about like two grand to get
um all started up so do you think i
should throw that or like save that and
uh put it towards i would just sit on
that foreground for right now and use
that to get your startup and get that
moving
yeah you're probably that's probably
pretty close you go to that part time
while you stay at the steer company
right correct yep yeah good good
because um i got my real estate license
when i turned 18 and i will go ahead and
tell you from a guy who's been there
it's tough to get people buy houses from
18 year old
right and i i expect that
you can do it i did it i sold houses but
the first one i saw was from a buddy of
mine from high school because he was as
dumb as i was but um
but then but he didn't get ripped off i
mean i did a good job but uh he paid 42
000 for the house and it's worth 842 now
but because that's how long ago i was in
high school but
[Laughter]
not 850. it's probably it's probably
worth 500 but yeah anyway the uh yeah so
just give yourself some grace on that
and you're gonna have to be really
really good at that profession to have
credibility
to be able to get people to transact
their home with a youngster and that's
not to say you can't do it it's not to
say you're not capable i'm just saying
how people are gonna perceive you
because that's how i was perceived
right okay and uh you then you'll have a
great story to tell when you're old so
you're gonna be great
you're doing good you're a sharp young
guy let's get the car paid off uh save
up and pay cash for the diamond then get
the car paid off lay out a budget for
the wedding execute on the budget if you
don't have a budget on the wedding
you'll pay double for it
because the but wedding budgets grow
based on the emotions of the
mother-in-law
i mean the bride
i mean your mother i mean
your dad wants people on the guest list
i mean
yeah there's a lot of people seem to
have a lot of fingers in your life when
you're building a wedding so you need a
game plan that you're going to stick to
and it doesn't get out of control
i'm very impressed with you quentin
though you are so intentional at this
age and just really are
just keeping your act together and
that's just impressive
way to go
yeah you're way ahead of the curve now
just don't stumble
and you know go crazy on this stuff but
yeah learn about um
clarity and carrot and learn about cut
and
learn about the flaws and a little flaw
in a diamond is a good thing bigger rock
less money and nobody's gonna if they
get their eye down real close to the
rock you just punch them so that's you
know you don't need it they don't need
to be looking with a glass at your
girlfriend's or your fiance's rock i
mean it's just crazy so that level of
intentionality though is just so
impressive and we were talking about the
couple the 25 year old couple earlier
this 18 year old he's paying off his
debt and it's like this is hard now but
then the 25 year old couple they've got
75 years of easy they're in baby step 7
just living their lives without a
payment in the world well they love you
predicting they're gonna live to a
hundred
speaking life over y'all
speaking life christina ellis speaking
life
yeah that's good though you're exactly
right i mean you got the rest of your
life you know no discipline seems
pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest of righteousness
so the theme for this hour has been easy
as hard
and hard is easy
i think that's called being a grown-up
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
you